man it's been a while since amonga made
me feel this excited YuYu Haka show is a
story of a legendary artist finding
their voice and honing their craft not
across decades but months it has been
one of the most fascinating reads I've
covered on this channel so far not so
much because of its story initially but
because it has essentially taken me on a
meta journey through an author's
transition from a romantic comedy writer
to a fully-fledged master of battle
shown it from his art style to the way
he weaves drama through combat yoshihiro
took aashi has evolved chapter after
chapter and upon hitting the Prelude to
the subject of this very video YuYu Haka
show was already feeling like a
completely different series the jumping
quality was palpable but now heading
right into the midst of a story arc I
here is widely considered one of the
very best in the genre I could not be
more excited to explore for the very
first time the mysterious brutal and
captivating Dark Tournament
Arc
fore
spee
foreign foreign
speech
foreign
[Music]
speech the end of the Prelude to this
very story left us on one hell of a
cliffhanger forced into competing in a
terrifying tournament by the Monstrous
toguro yusuke zoomed off to gen Kai's
place with pure determination to get
stronger and me in all of my manga
loving wisdom thought I'm sick training
Arc time but tagashi said no and jumped
right into the start of this tournament
this isn't the first time tagashi has
done this throughout this story but I
think it actually works remarkably well
here this tournament is essentially
throwing the characters and by extension
me the reader into totally Uncharted
Territory Togo's insanely strong but
what about the other contestants and
with only the tiniest glimpse into what
yusuke and his team have achieved over
the past two months it leaves every
moment of these early fights shrouded in
uncertainty considering these are fights
to the death well that sure does amp up
the tension to a whole other
level in many ways this almost feels
like a sort of reset emerging from the
forest with a mysterious partner yusuke
feels so I don't know different to the
punk kid that defines so much of the
prior material here he stands amidst a
veritable Army of demon onlookers and
he's just Camp after a brief test of
skills from he the gang hop onto his
ship to take them to the tournament but
quickly they're faced with a surprise
Battle Royale preliminary fight boy does
this feel familiar except one
thing
ah spaghetti the purpose of all this
Mystique is actually quite clever you
see had we seen the training our
participants underwent to get here as
many manga would have chosen to do by
this stage we would be deeply familiar
with our team's capabilities and all the
excitement would fall on their opponents
and ability to make good on that
training however now even our heroes act
as a point of excitement and
anticipation for us in addition to
whoever they may face much like Goku
showing up to the 23rd tenai Ichi buai
after his mysterious training only for
us to turn each page with baited breath
as he demonstrates just how far he's
come so too do we feel that with every
single character on team urameshi taking
that even further Togashi UPS the
uncertainty by including a massed
participant one who seems pretty clearly
to be Genai though that is quickly ruled
out by kuara and Co suspecting the very
same it's all just very mysterious and
though I am still not one 100% convinced
the mass fighter isn't Genai all I'm
really left to do is strap on my
metaphorical seat belt and find
out uncertainty might as well be tashi's
middle name at this point cuz he sure
ain't letting up with the rising tension
here as the gang relaxed in their hotel
room they're snuck up on by two members
of the team they'll soon face in their
first match Rinku and zeru while
narratively this scene exists to relay
some tournament rules and intimidate
yusuke's team what it's doing under the
hood is what I find to be the most
fascinating on one it's indicating the
level of skill in play here is beyond
anything the gang have seen before I
mean nobody noticed them sneak in that's
some creepy stuff right off the bat but
on the other hand it's helping to build
up this new yusuke he doesn't even stir
from his sleep leaving zedu to
essentially speak for the reader quote
did he sense we didn't intend to attack
or and that's it or that single word
ensured that I was locked in for at
least a hundred more pages and I'm not
kidding does he just not even consider
their power or threat just how much has
yusuke improved here on top of
everything else built up across these
early pages that alone is a thrilling
question to have linger as we head into
the very first
[Music]
match when I first saw that a single
tournament was going to span 60 chapters
on one hand part of me wor that it would
get stale after a while but on the other
hand I was well aware of the
tournament's positive reputation and
wondered how on Earth Togashi was going
to pull this off is it going to evolve
into a grander story or is it going to
be another situation where my experience
doesn't quite map on to the whiter
fandoms well I don't actually know I
write this as I read it but what Togashi
does do is establish a mechanic I've
never seen in a tournament setting
before and one that offers endless
possib abilities to keep things fresh
the team captains must agree on what
constitutes a battle and what counts as
a win if they can't agree on something
then each member fights one-on-one
effectively meaning no matter what the
narrative demands these battles can
facilitate it it's utterly genius and
what a spectacularly creative choice and
one that immediately doubts my fears of
the story ever feeling repetitive and
with the first match of agreeing to a
standard one-on-one bout it's time to
jump into battle team ureshi versus Team
Roku yukai in other stories I've read
that fall within the battle shown in
genre one aspect that I look out for as
the calling C of quality is the author's
ability to interweave the story Into the
battles that take place in the right
hands combat is very much the language
of battle Shonen and only the best do it
right and right out the gate tagashi
wastes no time in declaring that he's no
average manga as I've mentioned the
ability to define the terms of battle
affords each team's outing the chance to
take whatever shape is best suited to
whatever story Togashi is aiming to tell
and while I intend to talk about all of
my favorite fights individually I don't
intend on covering the minutia of every
single battle because well there's a lot
of them for instance this Team Battle
despite amounting to four separate
matchups really acts to establish the
setting the loose rules in play and most
importantly to test just how far Our
Heroes have come against foes that have
already been established as formidable
in other words this team battle is sort
of tashi's proof of concept for what
will eventually more or less become the
conclusion to this story and it's
delicious like I said two of these team
members sneak up on our heroes the night
before h two enemies one tall and
another short intimidating Our Heroes
where have I seen that before while the
best battle of this early matchup is
undoubtedly its climax these early
battles are nothing to scoff at either
kuara steps up as the first combatant
putting himself at an immediate
disadvantage against one of the only two
named fighters on the opposing team and
what's more is he loses but what's
masterful about this first outing isn't
the result necessarily but what the
result communicates to us as readers and
viewers while kabara did lose it was a
close match and one that stood to convey
both to his opponents as well as us
readers at home that team ureshi is not
quite as hopelessly outmatched as they
may
seem continuing this chaos and to
further establish team ureshi we see the
honorable Kurama face off against the
dishonorable Roto emphasizing the sort
of low lives we stand to face in this
tournament and the links they'll go to
in order to secure the win even in a
fight this seemingly unimportant Togashi
performs a narrative slight of hand by
setting up the expectation of Kurama as
The Honorable fighter only to completely
subvert that as he whips out scary PL no
Jutsu it's pretty gnarly stuff and
equally importantly tells us yet more
about how far these Heroes have
come
team team
here in the spirit of keeping every
fight feeling distinct he's bout is as
short as it is cathartic that is to say
very I'll be the first to admitted here
I got off to a rough start with he as a
character I thought his first outing in
the series was exceptional weak compared
to literally everything else that came
afterwards but it seems in addition to
this Tournament being a sort of reset
for yusuke and the world around him it
also acts as a sort of reintroduction
and reinvention of he into a more
traditional Powerhouse type character
for the team and it offers an
interesting Dynamic to Spruce things up
following the competitive and tense
Kurama bout what began as two mysterious
individuals intimidating the hero team
has now met a total role reversal he a
is a terrifying fly powerful Ally and
with this little beloved chaos Gremlin
Victory there are only two more members
left of the enemy
team oh I guess I got ahead of
myself yusuke versus Chu Togashi sure as
hell isn't hesitant in reminding us that
this isn't your typical Shonen battle
tournament there's a lot more room for
let's say improvisation which turns an
already exciting contest into a
thrilling spectacle and if there were
ever a contestant to throw things off
kilter it's this guy this is chu chu is
a drunken master a real brute and enough
of a threat to finally wake our hero
up oh yeah okay here we go yusuke's up
and in spite of Chu's menacing presence
he claims this is going to be light work
you could already cut this tension with
a knife but what's so fascinating is the
way Togashi uses the prior fights to
build this one up further it's not
exactly uncommon in battle manga to have
earlier fights appear easier only for
the final big bad to appear and surpass
their strength heck kurabara even
addresses this stating that things have
basically been a joke up until now but I
love that Kurama steps in to subvert
that very notion zeru according to him
was a genuine threat HEI literally had
to fall back on an imperfect technique
that we now know cost him the full use
of his arm but in spite of all of this
we're told that Chu is somehow even
worse and that certainly doesn't take
long to find out either as Chu catches
yusuke offg Guard from the GetGo but
what really stood out to me about this
section is togashi's artwork I've noted
the improvements to his writing so far
but it still cannot be understated just
how much of a jump togashi's paneling
has seen in tandem if we jump back only
a few volumes you'll find rigid battles
with stubbier characters and fairly
standard Line work which don't get me
wrong looks fine but doesn't exactly
have a dramatic Edge to it it feels in
line with the type of light-hearted work
Togashi had been writing prior to this
series but with the Prelude to this very
Arc his work changed dramatically yusuke
got taller his hair got Messier it
really started to look like a battle
manga now and as the dramatic battle
begins with chew togashi's training
weights are fully off and the master
that blew my mind with the stunning
Hunter Hunter art is finally starting to
emerge the loose line work the fluid
gesture not only did it fit the
description of chew's gliding moves but
it feels huge the impacts dance off the
page and the ink brush that Define much
of Hunter Hunter is starting to make an
appearance now the stuff is incredible
and I'm so glad the writing of this
fight matches it not only did yusuke
block chew's devastating kick with one
arm he walks that [__] off fires a ray
gun into the air just to show off his
move and then say he's only got three of
his daily four limit left what a baller
yusuke is now dead behold Chads I love
that Togashi just won't stop playing
with expectations also in this fight
first yusuke is overwhelmed then he's
fine then he's showing off his power and
then just to flip the battle on its head
Chu just laughs and Powers up even
further Conjuring a godamn energy ball
to rival yusuke's ray gun the ensuing
Clash of raiki and fist is so unbel un
believably good and yet it ends in a
total
[Music]
stalemate I said you could cut the
tension of this fight with a knife and
it's like Togashi heard me the rule of
being able to decide what constitutes a
win was one I said fascinated me and it
didn't take long for that mechanic to
come into play Chu whips out two kn
knives driving them into the ground to
Mark the zones and says that not only
will the person who falls out of this
lose but they'll pay with their life and
best of all with everyone's raiki spent
this will be a battle of pure physical
strength I love this for so many reasons
I'm always a sucker for fights that fall
down to mutual respect between battle
obsessed Warriors but to flip the script
on the dynamic of the battle midways
through is such a sick idea it keeps
things fresh and to impose physical
limitations like this just opens the
doors for so many fascinating twists and
turns this battle explodes off the page
in spite of the lack of raiki it feels
bigger than anything we've seen before
it is beyond brutal blood sparts from
their heels against the knives with
every crushing blow culminating in the
most insane headbutt it's like time
stops and everyone looks on unsure
before Chu slumps to the floor def
defeated covered in blood and bruises
yusuke turns to Rinku and
says our main character everyone that
genuinely is just straight up one of the
best battles I've consumed in quite some
time it is such a spectacular
reintroduction to this new version of
yusuke and with this being only the
climax of the first battle it is so
clear to me that not only am I in for a
good time in this Arc but Togashi has
completely emerged from his cocoon as a
master of battle Shonen the purpose of
the first team's battle was to establish
the culture rules and atmosphere of this
tournament itself but this final fight
was all of that in microcosm a clash for
the ages and one of the best fights I've
ever seen but again that's not going to
be the last time I'll say that in this
video team urameshi versus team ichigaki
with the first hurdle out of the way
that brings us to day two of the
tournament where Togashi introduces us
to team ichigaki who appears to be a
head or two more barbaric than the last
batch but given their introduction is
the most Savage yet showcasing the most
brutal dismemberment I figured we needed
some levity in the room but yes these
are the folks team ureshi are up against
next and things are not looking good
here yusuke can summon any Aura after
rapid firing his ray gun last round he's
arm is beyond messed up and they've just
gotten the news that they'll be up
against team toguro if they progress any
further but it gets even worse with
Kurama and he Ambush leaving the team
with only three members I figured after
the setup of this team's brutality and
team urameshi put on the back foot that
Togashi was sort of gearing up for a
sense of desperation and that would be
the lynchpin in ensuring this next
battle felt different from the prior but
I honestly could not have been more
wrong in fact the emphasis of this
section is hardly on the action itself
heck it's hardly on team Ur Mesi at all
kuara has a dream about a group of
Martial Arts students lamenting their
inability to pay for their sick Master's
treatment only for someone called ich
Kaki to roll up and offer to save him if
they'll agree to take part in one of his
experiments throughout these chapters
both Kurama and the mass fighter note
that these opponents are definitely not
here of their own valtion and so this 3
on3 Battle Royale is no longer black and
white I adore that from a narrative
point of view the change in format was
interesting enough but to throw a moral
conundrum into a death match is amazing
ichigaki is a real bastard and so it
really becomes less about the two teams
facing each other and more about them as
a colle versus this monstrous scientist
and trying to figure a way out of this
horrible situation now don't get me
wrong the battle itself is still full of
some great team up moments and Togashi
even throws a spanner into the works
when the mass fighter shroud falls off
revealing not Gen Kai but a young girl
what but to me it's learning about this
team and how to get out of this
situation that gave this segment of the
tournament so much strength after
escaping their Ambush he and Kurama
literally drop into the arena and reveal
the heinous crimes committed ichigaki
caused their Master to fall ill in the
first place and all in the name of
creating that chance to perform this
sick experiment the mad scientist goes
on further to reveal they're all
infested with blood control nodes and
okay I almost groaned thinking that this
was one of those cases where the idiot
monologuing villain was going to give
away their key to Victory but thankfully
tashi's a bit better than that and it
turns out these things are permanent you
remove them and the host will die and
man does the story get Bleak from here
on it these poor martial artists cry out
for death quite literally crying blood
through sheer desperation and in
response to this yusuke's rage knows no
bounds as he accepts he will have to No
Doubt put these people down and out of
their misery
[Music]
until the Mast fighter steps in without
hesitation she drives her hand into the
hearts of the three opponents casting
purify and well I think it's probably
clear where this is going there's a
death fake out for the three and team
ureshi wins the fight I was initially a
little thrown off by how neatly this
seemed to be tied up he and Kurama
revealed they found and cured the mentor
yusuke obliterates the mad scientist and
hey the three students are even alive I
was all prepared to criticize how
convenient it all felt and I suppose it
still is to a certain extent but I think
the way it's conveyed stops IT feeling
cheap the mass fighter reveals that what
she did wasn't some miracle cure it was
a move that judges the host souls and if
that soul is pure any Corruptions are
purified the three were only saved
because they are at their core good
people with the Sensei proclaiming pride
in their Incorruptible Hearts I just
kind of got swept up in the poignancy of
it all corruptible power is such a key
theme of this Arc and to see such a
positive resolution here was genuinely
moving I might not necessarily adore the
way the pieces of this fight's
resolution are put together but when
it's emotional way and development of
the tournament's key themes are front
and center like this it's very easy to
overlook any flaws the quarterfinals
Shadow channelers versus Team urshi yeah
if uh if you thought that transition
felt sudden then you'd be right the next
fight starts right away no breaks and I
really like how the narrative is taking
every opportunity to make team ur's
presence in this tournament feel
completely stifling they came into this
as underdogs and things sure take a turn
for the worse here as the odds continue
to be stacked against them as yusuke
puts it this tournament is just a
grinder and they're the meat the shadow
channelers are the most aesthetically
consistent and mysterious so far a
disguise for a series of ninja demons
that Kurama explains live exclusively
for Carnage nothing like bloodthirsty
ninjas to off the anti and to make
matters worse with kabara down for the
count last round and the rest of the
team drained of energy team urameshi
isn't just the fish outof water team
they are completely outgunned with only
three members battle ready togashi's
carea a sense of well-earned tension
leaving me to wonder how on Earth are
they going to get out of this one much
like the last round it's not so much the
super entertaining battles that sit at
the Forefront of the narrative here but
instead it's what this matchup tells us
about the tournament in spite of
everything against them things are only
getting worse Genai and he are lured off
to some medical tent to check their
wounds only to find themselves trapped
there and deemed medically unfit to
participate and with kurabara out of
action this leaves only yusuke and
Kurama in a fit state of fight in this
horrifically biased matchup mercifully
the foran agreed upon is a series of
one-on-one battles a true battle of
attrition and boy does it deliver in
every sense of the word Kurama steps up
assuring yusuke he'll get them to reveal
their strategies while the rest may very
well fall on him kurama's first opponent
is a brush wielder named GMA a body
paint Bearer whose ink made from his own
blood by the way imparts curses upon
those he marks it is a brutal battle one
that pushes Kurama to the edge and yet
despite winning the markings left upon
him keep his Aura sealed for 10 minutes
after gma's death I am not kidding when
I say this entire segment had me feeling
like Jesus I hope Kurama can avoid dying
long enough to get some points on the
board here each battle just feels like
the disadvantages continue to pile up
for this poor guy up until now I had
enjoyed this character but my emotional
investment in him during this early
tournament wasn't super in depth just
yet but wow does that change here the
next opponent is an ice demon called toy
the top rank of those scenes so far he
is
fishlyn and man the way Kurama wins this
is so big brain Toya jumps in close for
the finishing blow only for Kurama to
impale him out of godamn nowhere turns
out this Sly Fox infected his open
wounds with his deadly ve fch to take
the win I mean you can keep the aura in
if it's bleeding out so it all adds up
the absolute Noggin on this lad and if
anything is apparent in this match is
that Togashi really just Revels in the
suffering of it all this should be by
right the end of the fight and
[Music]
yet if there were ever a way to make me
fall in love with a character it's
through these Last Stand moments the
sheer corruption running through this
matchup is such a fascinating way of
making it feel distinct from the other
one-on ones in the tournament thus far
and it really says a lot about how
carefully tagashi considered each of
these bouts and most importantly the
character work within them and that
could not be more true than right
here this is how you bring a character
back into play marrying kurama's dire
circumstances and yusuke's personality
into a bombastic interjection that
shifts things up a gear this is yusuke
no matter the consequences no matter
what those in charge say yusuke will
stand by and do the right thing
especially for his allies this one shot
of him silently aiming down bakuen from
the sidelines all the while his teammate
describes what's about to happen to him
if he doesn't release Kurama is
seriously effective with yusuke taken to
the stage Togashi breaks the fourth wall
as our hero utters I'll wrap this up in
a two page
[Music]
spread where's the chats gaming where's
the chats there he is there's my guy the
next fight against jyn is pure Cinema I
mean this dude is basically just a goofy
Goku type who flies around enjoying the
thrill of battle it's a great bit of
spectacle and some much needed levity
after the intensity of Kurama struggles
it results in a seemingly convincing win
leaving only one fight for the shadow
channelers left that being risho
fortunately for us and unfortunately for
Our Heroes the way tagashi massively
orchestrates the level of tension
throughout this bout is crazy precise
this should carry with it the momentum
forward of the ties turning in favor of
team ureshi but it doesn't under
instructions from the higher Ops Rio
puts forth the case that yusuke's
Victory should be disqualified on
account of a slow count performed by the
referee in the prior conflict and given
where this idea came from in the first
place those very powers that be
naturally agree that this is the case
and just like that it's over what a
slimy way to
[Music]
win okay okay I wish I could tell you
how godamn ecstatic this made me it
literally caught me so off guard filled
me with so much adrenaline that I damn
near hired a private investigator to
hunt down togashi's personal address so
I could person L massage his aching back
in thanks this moment made me more hyped
than just about any page of any manga
I've ever read and I am not just saying
that it's moments like this that remind
me why I love the medium of manga so
much this act tells you everything you
need to know about kabara and why he's
my new favorite character in this story
definitively there's no others being the
strongest is cool being the best
designed is cool and being kind is
underrated but seeing the weakest
character on the team fearlessly step up
to the plate when no one else can all in
the name of saving lives knowing he's
marching towards almost certain death
himself is one of the most powerful
moments this Series has conjured so far
few stories can pull this off as
effectively as this can thousands of
people have claimed over the years that
this is the best tournament Arc in the
medium and as I read this I'm finding it
increasingly hard to argue against that
point this is phenomenal and earned in
every con conceivable respect and in
addition to all of that in the heat of
this courageous moment kabara utter
perhaps my favorite line in this entire
manga I'd love to bust this place open
myself but can't we show these cheating
scumbags even at our worst we are better
maybe it's because I'm a sap maybe it's
the climate we live in these days but
those words kabara uttered to yusuke
legitimately made me emotional while I
was reading during these matchups the
most Prejudice and crooked set of
encounters kabara chooses to be better
in a world where we glorify an eye for
an eye as long as it aligns with our own
ideologies this sentiment was one that
hit me right in the fields when I needed
it the most we need to celebrate More
Heroes like this it should go without
saying that this stunning moment results
in a victory for team ureshi how could
it not and yet the moment is one of
perfect comedy a brutal one hit KO upon
kurabara noticing yukina has arrived in
the arena silly doesn't even begin to
cut it and yet I think it was perhaps
the very best choice Togashi could have
ever made the scope and emotional weight
of these matchups continues to grow and
with each passing round and with each
singular moment topping anything prior I
wait with baited breath as to what lies
ahead of me here yusuke's training in
battle Shonen training sequences or
reprieves from Battle have become a
staple of the genre a sort of prolonged
period of struggle used to position the
main character for an upcoming conflict
in line with the themes of the story
Dragon Ball most notably has a great
many training arcs Naruto too heck even
Hunter Hunter has them but what I found
interesting about this particular one
with yuu Haka shows is the timing of the
training itself there have been plenty
of opportunities for yusuke and his
allies to train we've even been told
that this training has taken place or at
worst it's been suggested that but it
always remained offc screen it almost
suggests that these moments aren't
important important however nothing
could be further from the truth for a
writer the acts of including and
excluding something are both creative
choices choices that serve a specific
purpose we see Goku learn the Spirit
Bomb on King Kai's Planet but nothing is
shown of the kaio-ken up until the
moment it's used in battle it creates
narrative Mystique around it all the
while with the Spirit Bomb we understand
it completely and are aware of it in
Goku's back pocket when the Kaioken
appears we're shocked and when the last
ditch Spirit Bomb is used we feel the
tension well aware of how long it takes
for Goku to build that monster up what
was seen and ultimately unseen was
purposly weaved that way for surprise
and tension and Togashi has used that to
great effect so far we stepped into this
tournament with no idea of what yusuke
learned off screen and that provided
great payoff with awesome surprises but
now tagashi gives the reader a direct
view of the training for a very specific
reason this intense struggle yusuke
undertakes is important to witness both
in in terms of setup for future plot
points and what it does thematically the
training itself is framed as the last
test Genai will ever give yusuke
insinuating that either she won't be
long for this world or yusuke will
simply have no need for her any longer
at any rate she continues to talk about
the natural Order of Things how as you
get older you gain wisdom and experience
but those years also rob you of your
natural strength quote nature gives us
our time and then we step aside for the
Next Generation NE within this
conversation Togashi plants a single
panel of toguro during all of this
almost as if it were included by mistake
but then she asks yusuke an important
question this is a test a test to
confirm something yet unknown to us as a
reader but for whatever reason Gen Kai
needs to know where yusuke's True Values
lie would he really do anything for
power he says that he will so Genai
tests that very Theory asking him to
kill her suddenly it starts to rain
heavily as if to mimic the storm of
confusion whirling within yusuke's mind
it's a dilemma with a clear outcome but
his moral compass prevents him from
taking action he's forced to contend
with where he as a human draws that line
and as he crosses the threshold into the
Cal atmosphere of the cave out of the
storm suddenly it all becomes clear this
test wasn't trying to measure if yusuke
could follow through on a harrowing act
in the name of the greater good it was a
test to see if he was indeed a moral
person someone deserving of gen Kai's
power revealingly in this circumstance
yusuke was again presented with a
dilemma in order to accept this power
yusuke needs to risk his life according
to Genai there's a high likelihood of a
horrible death if you're not strong
enough to accept this power so naturally
yusuke has two options here to take it
or not but he doesn't even hesitate
however it's not for nothing he knows
that in order to stand a chance at
competing against toguro he needs to get
stronger a lot stronger he won't kill
someone for that chance but he will risk
his own life because those he cares
about are counting on them and by Far
and Away my favorite aspect of this
entire struggle yuk quietly yours in
this cave is the consequence of the egg
earlier in the tournament kenma Jr makes
an appearance in an all new getup and
hands yusuke the very egg he was tasked
to protect in the very first Arc that he
forgot about this egg feeds off of
yusuke's Aura and will hatch into
something depending on the content of
yusuke's character and well when it does
hatch it's this hilarious looking
creature however lying there in the cave
having collapsed in agony yusuke appears
to be losing this internal fight maybe
he can't accept this power maybe he's
not the right person he needs water he's
going to
[Music]
die for as silly as this thing looks
this is the living manifestation of all
the good that yusuke is and stands to
offer the world he arrives in the nick
of time to offer Aid helping yusuke make
it to the other side of this in what
little way it can and it's a wonderful
metaphor that demonstrates that not only
is yusuke now ready for the next
challenge but Genai didn't make a
mistake by choosing him as her successor
what uplifts yusuke isn't a self-serving
desire but instead a deep compulsion and
need to protect others a trait
demonstrated through his action for his
teammates his desire to help that little
creature Pooh and of course Koo yusuke
has come a long way since the first
chapter of this
story
[Music]
and so this moment exists to make a
point a pivotal one and one I'd like to
say for the Epic conclusion of this
wonderful Arc Fractured Fairy Tales and
team ureshi with yusuke's training
underway toosi plays around with
structure for the first time in this
tournament throughout the affir mention
section the battle between the rest of
team ureshi and their current opponents
the Fractured Fairy Tales is well
underway and toosi cuts between the two
plot points for a very specific reason
this matchup isn't really about some
narrative within the battles themselves
like everything up until this point has
been instead it exists to establish
where everyone's power is at he
obliterates his first opponent and then
pulls off the most insane Victory
against the next showcasing a flame
infused AA sword a glimpse of just how
deep his connection to the flame goes
kurama's battle exhibits the most
stunning of showcases with his enemy
using a reverse Magic Box an item pulled
from folklore that rewinds age on anyone
affected by its Smoky contents intent on
taking Kurama back to a child in hopes
of beating him then instead it reverts
him back to his terrifyingly powerful
fox form with a moment of tension when
he realizes he's doomed without Mastery
of this form and yet interestingly we
see little of kabara instead playing up
his segment for jokes as the enemy
repeatedly teleports him away from the
battlefield instead of this it shows Gen
Kai effortlessly clear the battle it had
me questioning why Togashi was doing
this Beyond comment
an answer I will soon find in the finale
and with the following segment revolving
around a Showcase of Togo's team
ruthlessly dispatching their opponents I
think it's pretty clear to see the
contrast to gashi is trying to create
here this is where everyone stands their
strengths their weaknesses the
uncertainty of their Trump cards all set
against a backdrop of yusuke struggling
harder than any of them to achieve his
goal but it's what occurs immediately
after this that really ties this all
together and creates the most nail
biting tension impossible going into the
climax Genai versus toguro it's
difficult to downplay just how vital
this segment is to the broader story
it's the convergence and coming together
of two characters who played bit roles
in Prior arcs now acting as the glue
that elevates this from a very fun
tournament to one I'll think about for
many years to come an everpresent
mystery surrounding the mass fighter in
this Arc has been that of their identity
and the subversion that took place when
she was initially revealed to be much
younger looking during combat in the
hands of a lesser writer this mystery
would have remained just that and no one
would have minded it however Togashi
decided to leverage that very surprise
into a mechanism that ties everything
thematically together with toguro in
this Arc both toguro and Genai represent
two opposing sides to a particular
argument this Arc is trying to resolve
having trained in martial arts together
as they grew up a Darkness brought on by
the natural passage of time crept into
toguro's mind all of that power he spent
his life acquiring he doesn't want to
give it up he doesn't want to stand
aside for the Next Generation choosing
instead to sell his soul to the devil in
order to retain his youthful demeanor
and his strength becoming the very
monster that haunts yusuke in this Ark
as seen earlier gen Kai's powers are
inextricably tied to her youthful
appearance meaning while she hands down
her power for yusuke to inherit she is
also openly communicating that it's not
her youth that's valuable it's the
values yusuke holds that are there will
always be need for good values there
will always be more youth to inherit it
it's not important for her to retain her
power and her youth part of the circle
of life is for the old and wise to hand
down that wisdom to the young to carry
forth that what we should encourage is
kindness not
[Music]
greed this isn't how these sorts of
stories go just mere seconds ago during
the tournament I spoke of how that
entire segment was designed to give us
an idea of where the gang is currently
to establish a narrative foothold from
which we can launch into the finals on
for Genai to die in her pupil's arms at
this moment while tragic while serving
to demonstrate how reprehensible and
lost toguro is it also completely undo
all certainty going forward which is
[Music]
perfect the buildup to this moment is
Solemn he struggles to match the power
of toguro despite his determination even
through im's training Kurama cannot even
dream of besting katasu yusuke sits in
the aftermath of gen Kai's death staring
at the cave his master set him upon it's
a series of Stark and depressing moments
that emphasize the feeling of all hope
being lost so incredibly well but I
think where Togashi in his later years
might have left this hopelessness to
linger he's careful in instilling a
sense of hope on this occasion a
contestant from the prior round reveals
a history with toguro and hands Kurama
and kabara two items to Aid in their
battle a potion form of what restored
kurama's Fox powers and a magical hilt
for kabara set to unleash a blade
modeled on the nature of the one who
wields it and while these are physical
manifestations of Hope to turn the tides
it's kenma's delivery of genkai's final
message that reignites yusuke's own hope
don't cross over just
winu
[Music]
this powerful response is a culmination
of these moments a message to toguro and
his gang that they will not be beaten
down by tragedy Instead This is the
spark that will ignite a fire on under
them and lead them to
[Applause]
[Music]
Victory team ureshi versus Team
toguro these battles kick off with so
much energy with karasu and Kurama
taking to the arena first it's a brutal
display and one of Na biting intensity
Togashi drops a detail that the
inestable version of the fox form
restoration magic takes a while to kick
in and so this battle is one long
waiting game and boy oh boy when it
finally does kick in the imagery is
incredible and yet somehow this doesn't
bring about Victory as I was expecting
karasu's own trick up his sleeve is
equally as impressive and with Kurama
seemingly knocked out of his own fox
form Togashi has ramped up the tension
to all new heights this is all in
service of creating a moment I wasn't
convinced by at first with Kurama out of
all options he's forced to use a move
that will end his own life and he does
just that he uses everything he has to
summon a devastatingly powerful blow
against katasu and wins except he
doesn't die potions effects in fact
return him to his human body a
reunification of kurama's human form and
the fox Spirit at first I can't say I
love this it seemed to me like a sudden
and convenient Victory but upon closer
inspection it dawned on me that this was
earned this was a full circle moment
once a fox Spirit who gave up his power
reluctantly accepting Humanity to
survive now willing to give up his life
for others and rewarded with the
restoration of his fox demon self and
he's battle against Buie is ultimately
no different with Kurama deemed the
loser due to some nonsensical
technicality he puts himself forward to
take on this brute despite aspirations
to fight to
he yields this right to yusuke for Gen
Kai's sake he says this change in he is
hardly a new one we've seen this through
his actions in this Arc already but to
hear it voiced is a powerful moment he
has been characterized through
selfishness and a desire to dominate his
very own technique was understood to be
about Mastery over demonic fire the
black dragon time and time again he
failed almost losing his arm in the
process but here here he Masters it not
through Domin
but through Acceptance in some respects
him and the black dragon become one and
it's that enhancement from within that
leads to Victory it's a stunning moment
of poetry and a real high point for this
[Music]
tournament perhaps more than anyone it's
kuwabara's match that feels the most
overt in its conveyance of character
work the Elder toguro morphs into
versions of Genai mocking not just her
death but kuwabara's inability to
understand the reality of her absence in
this round this entire battle is a test
of character of perseverance and
hardiness in the face of adversity and
despite kuwabara's presence always on
the lighter side of things in this
tournament there's an intentional and
uncharacteristic gravitas to this
victory that really spoke to me not in
the act itself but the aftermath kabara
berats and rages at yusuke for not
telling him about Genai and after yusuke
wistfully recounts his reasoning kabara
turns away and in one of the most
stunning panels of this chapter he says
only two
words beat him with those powerful words
echoing through his mind yusuke is now
ready and steps up to face
Togo I
am
isol I am the cler of my
leg
[Applause]
I this is without a doubt one of the
greatest battles I've ever seen
Illustrated jumping up to 80% from the
start Togashi illustrates Togo with the
most insane brush work I've ever seen
this man is a hulking monstrosity that
physically looms over yusuke from page
to page the speed from panel to panel is
honestly startling and as things ramp up
Togashi falls back on looser shapes to
contrast toguro's terrifying agility in
contrast to robust illustrative
close-ups found elsewhere and that's not
even mentioning the way this battle is
choreographed there are upside down ray
guns Arena destroying blasts and oh my
God it has the classic I was holding
back all this time moment when yusuke
drops his Aura handcuffs this is Battle
shown in Beauty toguro's jump to his
100% form is just insane look at these
Pages look at them it is pure
unadulterated Talent from Togashi
spinning out of every single panel and
what's more is my man Togo blocks a
blast with a single shout before
uttering the coldest line I've ever read
I love this I love this I almost lost my
damn mind when he seemingly took out
kabara the resulting moments are so
beyond breathtaking this is genuine
battle shown in Perfection and yet in
spite of all this stunning spectacle
this is only a tiny fraction of why I
adore this
fight during my reviews I often feel
compelled to delve into the past of the
artist behind the stories I'm covering
hoping to get a snapshot into the mind
and soul that's invited me into his
world through his stories however during
my coverage of Hunter Hunter yoshihiro
took ASI in intimidated me or rather his
approach to manga creation did you got
to remember because this is my job and I
set myself a reading goal every week to
hit when I cover a new story I
effectively throw myself into that world
entirely day after day until it's done
and chapter after chapter and Arc after
Arc as the weeks ticked on by I could
feel the thin veil of happiness and joy
that informed Hunter Hunter's early
chapters slowly give way and reveal the
true Bedrock of that story The
complicated emotional distress of its
creator permeated every page every pen
stroke every single word to say that it
caused me distressed by the Finish would
be an understatement when you hang
around negativity all day you start to
feel the same way and in an effort to
prevent that from happening further to
myself I stopped looking into Tashi
altogether so much so that had it not
been for the comments under those very
reviews I would never have known that
there was a series called YuYu Haka show
associated with him in the first place
how however I fixed that during my
coverage of this Arc as I noted last
week in the same way that I could see
how much yuu Haka show had influenced or
set the groundwork for Hunter Hunter
this week I can see just how much
togashi's earlier work 10day show outu
Cupid influenced This Magnificent series
YuYu Haka show and indeed the final
matchup with toguro himself 10day sheru
cupid is a four volume romance manga
chronicling the life of a young boy and
a devil girl that description feels
totally analogous to what took gashi is
known for nowadays however the
Fingerprints of that subtle appreciation
for The Human Condition and emotion have
always lingered long after the series
concluded it's no secret that accepting
a surface level observation as a reader
of tagashi stories betrays a an
ignorance of the beauty his work stands
to offer informing every seemingly
light-hearted action in Hunter Hunter is
a quiet sadness and underneath every
uplifting Crescendo in YuYu Haka show is
a peaceful Serenity and appreciation for
the finer details to a passive Observer
yusuke versus Togo is simply a story's
hero overcoming the crude brute in the
name of what is right and there's
certainly some truth to that but like I
said moments earlier accepting just that
as the substance of this story betrays
an ignorance of what yoshihiro Togashi
is capable of giving you I've seen a few
folks online describe this Arc as
aimless or lacking in substance and when
you consider that there's a looming
threat revealed moments before the final
that we haven't been privy to through Mr
SA I can sort of understand how some
people might feel that way about it
however for me I honestly felt that it
was not only a phenomenally well-
written and well-conceived of ending but
it was in fact one of the most
effectively uplifting endings in an arc
I've read ever and what's more is the
other fights surrounding it and building
up to this Clash Echo the sentiments
contained therein in one way or another
these individual fights speak to a
choice or some element of Team ur's past
Kurama versus katasu and he versus Buie
both feature Our Heroes contending with
the choices or circumstances of their
past both displayed in very different
ways resulting in very different
outcomes a former Fox Spirit struggling
to reignite the power that wants to find
him forced to rely on his own selfless
and sacrificial nature to make up the
difference and a demon once Shackled by
a desperate Gambit now having mastered
the unthinkable culminating in one of
the most satisfying conclusions to any
of the fights except
for one yusuke versus toguro our true
main event and the climax of not just
this Arc but the manga up until this
point this fight is a masterpiece and I
don't throw that word around lightly
masterpieces in battle shown in are sort
of rare by Design they are often the
culmination of everything concerning the
themes story and participants involved
up until that point in the manga
everything converges in one perfectly
powerful Point leaving everything on the
page with nothing held back only a few
fights come to mind when I consider this
criteria Goku versus Vegeta is an
obvious one the proud saiyan elite
versus the lower class commoner and in
the end it's what made Goku who he was
that ultimately made the difference in
that Clash of ideologies this is all to
say of course that for a masterpiece of
battle Shonen to be considered such it
needs to say something more than just
the fighting itself something about the
characters the themes and on some level
has to create a power ful and resonant
connection between itself and US reading
along yusuke versus toguro is that
Masterpiece mechanically speaking how
these two characters and their
personalities are designed and
complement each other lends itself
poetically in some ways to what Togashi
is trying to achieve with this final
battle consider this the inciting
incident that launches this story into
full swing is a single Choice Yus game
makes a choice to save a small child
from being hit by a car he didn't need
to do this but who he is forced him to
act this paired with his loud crass bad
boy demeanor and you've got for yourself
someone who feels very much like an
active character within his story one
that dictates where it goes and drives
it forward and then he meets toguro at
the end of The Last Arc I'm not talking
about this meeting I'm talking really
meeting the real toguro when he
challenges him to the tournament proper
yusuke is objetive terrified triggering
a fear response and urgency within him
that pushes him to seek out Gen Kai for
more strength more power and as the arc
begins we see he's achieved just that
there's something totally different
about yusuke in this moment he's
different he's changed and this fact is
tangibly tackled at two separate
instances during the story itself I'll
touch on the most obvious
firstop
so this is one of the most pivotal
moments in the ark's second half one
that plays into the Finish beautifully
and one that serves to reaffirm for us
who yusuke is and this is important
because that's actually a massive part
of this manga story and most importantly
the climax itself unable to accept who
he is what he is toguro rejects the
natural Order of Things rejecting the
person that he is in favor of gaining
everything he desires power and lots of
it in the pursuit of Eternal Youth and
this great selfish power he's forced to
relinquish his own Humanity his allies
himself in the process this we later
learn is what Genai is testing yusuke
with by asking him to kill her it's his
final test having rushed to her side
driven by fear following toguro's
challenge yusuke much like toguro has
been driven by a desire to get stronger
but will he do anything to get stronger
no not anything in a moment of utter
dialogue poetry Togashi pens a response
so perfect for yusuke's character to
utter it both made me laugh and gave me
chills all at once in response to her
request to kill her he simply says I'm
going to have to fail this test it won't
be the last chef's kiss and through
choosing this path yusuke proves that
he's indeed the right person to inherit
gen Kai's energy but I digress why bring
this up at all well from the get-go I
sort of Saw toguro as what yusuke could
have been if he were morally bankrupt
enough or desperate enough to allow his
darkest desires to dictate who he was
and in the end it was that comparison
that was made between the two and the
differences that were emphasized that
made their final fight as compelling As
It ultimately was for me but I was only
half right in my estimation because I
actually totally misread what sort of
character yusuke was in the closing
moments of the fight toguro taunts
yusuke by insinuating that he is similar
to to himself and I could almost see
that being the case they both appear to
be active and abrasive characters
willing to push for strength to achieve
their goals however there was a
fundamental difference at play here one
that I didn't fully appreciate until the
very end because yusuke isn't an active
character at all the group of ban
yusuke's mom and Koo flounder around a
lot in this Arc with their main purpose
being a cheer section for tagashi to cut
to in order to add some variety to the
commentary on each fight they view but
but there is one vital piece of story
offered by KO when she arrives at the
tournament grounds she says that she
doesn't want to stop yusuke from
participating despite her desire for him
to be safe because he looks like he's
happier here it's a blink and you miss
it moment but it speaks to the core of
yusuke I think quite profoundly despite
being surrounded by monsters yusuke only
has eyes for his friend's safety for the
first time in his life he feels as
though he has a purpose which if you you
cast your mind's back stands in stark
contrast to how he was depicted in the
very first chapter where he in a sort of
apathetic way didn't see the urgency or
need to even come back to life at all
his opinion on what he offered the world
had been molded by the teachers fellow
students and other kids in his life
telling him consistently that he was
nothing more than a bad kid a torment
and drain on society but in this group
of Misfits he's found a place that not
only he can do well in but in fact
contrib good to also and so in what I
had initially thought was a clash of two
individuals with similar motivations
valuing different things in the end it
actually amounted to a coming together
of two polar opposite forces and this is
reflected in the art direction of the
fight too where toguro is penned in this
sharp vicious and almost uncomfortable
detail countless times over yusuke is
the embodiment of Tranquility like
toguro is a hurricane and yusuke the eye
of of that hurricane during this battle
it's revealed that Togo The Man Who Sold
his soul for his own selfish desires
actually does have some minor redemption
in the end a doubt or guilt rather
that's informed his actions his pursuit
of someone stronger enough to give him
what he thinks he deserves and the boy
who once had nothing to live for who was
convinced he was a waste of space
finally found his reason to live not
just for others but for himself also he
found where he belongs he was never a
bad kid he was always a misunderstood
hero who would sooner throw his own life
into the line of fire than to risk
anyone else's the climax of this fight
isn't a full circle moment for either
character it's a realization and
acceptance of who they each are and
there's something remarkably poignant
about that and so in the same way that
those in yusuke's life took him at face
value and misjudged him characterizing
him as nothing more than a bad kid so
too does yoshihiro togashi's magnificent
dark tournament Arc offer a subtly
sophisticated story rich with heart
waiting to be appreciated you just have
to be open to seeing
it in conclusion the epilogue to this
Arc is one of redemption one
characterized by a brief conversation
between toguro and Genai in the
afterlife a moment that solidifies the
themes of this Arc and offers a
heart-wrenching final word from toguro
quote sorry to have been so much trouble
it's a beautiful bow on this gift of an
arc in a moment that truly solidified my
feelings towards this tournament my only
understanding going into this story was
that this Arc was considered a
masterpiece of the genre and as I write
this on the other side of having
experienced it I can confidently say
tagashi lived up to and surpassed those
very expectations on every conceivable
level but I can't help but look at this
story in comparisons made by its fans to
other tournaments within the medium
without feeling like they're missing the
forest for the trees Dragon Ball's ten
Kai ich buai my hero Academia sports
festival Arc countless tournaments exist
in battle Shonen but they all have such
unique tonality and aims that I find the
comparisons odd superficial even the
equivalent of comparing Wall-E and
Aliens simply because they're both set
in space YuYu Haka Show's Dark
Tournament was every bit The Arc that
was promised and then some it's a
sophisticated and elegant execution of a
Classic Tournament archetype that oozes
with the flashes of greatness that made
Hunter Hunter a household name it's a
masterpiece of battle Shonen
storytelling a compelling character
study and boasted more incredible
artwork than I've ever seen from Togashi
on such a consistent basis but I wonder
does its emphasis on character
complexity make it inherently Superior
to works less interested in such an
approach or is it just different as I
prepare for the final stretch of This
Magnificent story I'd be curious to hear
what you think in that regard yuu Haka
show is incredible and I will see you
all next time for the thrilling
conclusion to this incredible
[Music]
story